[Music]
this is one of the most famous and one
of the most difficult works in Western
philosophy it's by Georg Friedrich
Wilhelm Hegel it's called the
phenomenology of spirit and this month
I'm going to be offering three online
events one of them free for the general
public where we're going to be delving
into one of the most often commented on
sections the master-slave dialectic from
self-consciousness in the phenomenology
of spirit if you'd like to join me we're
offering like I said a free webinar
that's going to happen on Tuesday June
20th at 12 p.m. Central time so you want
to make sure to get the timezone right
that's going to go on for about 45
minutes we'll have about 20 minutes of
that being Q&A I have a number of useful
resources so you're not going into a
completely cold but you will want to
actually get yourself a copy of the text
if you want to join us for that and we
can have as many people as want to sign
up for that free webinar then on
Saturday June 24th for those who want a
much more intensive learning experience
we're going to be offering our monthly
online intensive seminars at 10 a.m. and
4 p.m. we offer to them in part because
these are much smaller sections 12
people maximum we like to keep it a
little bit you know close and almost
intimate so that I can give as much
attention to the learners as possible we
include a lot of time for Question and
Answer those actually enroll for $49
it's well worth it if you ever wanted to
try to work your way through this text
if you've tried reading it and you
couldn't quite grasp what was going on
I've been reading and rereading mostly
rereading Hegel's phenomenology of
spirit for over 20 years I'm the
producer of the half-hour Hegel project
I've got some videos useful for you if
you want to delve into it but if you
really want it in
pensive learning experience you want to
click on the links below in the video
description and check out the online
seminar like I said though if you aren't
quite sure whether that's for you
pop into the webinar on Tuesday June
20th see whether you like it or not see
whether you want a bit more and I'll be
happy to see you there
[Music]